well as we celebrate the Day of love we
wanted to bring you the story of a Las
Vegas couple married for almost six
decades I love these old wedding
pictures The Potter's Love Story began
as teenagers right here in the valley
Victoria Saha takes us through their
Journey
after she'd be my Valentine sure
I always have been she's awful lucky
no he's a lucky one it's been a
whirlwind of nearly 60 years of marriage
for these lovebirds with four kids eight
grandkids and four great grandkids and
their secret to a happy long marriage we
just force our opinion and you work it
out I'm not changing now it's too late
their love story goes back to the 1950s
when Raymond and Patricia were both a 16
attending Las Vegas high school she was
driving a 36 Ford Coupe up 7th Street by
the football field at Vegas high school
and I saw her and it had a for sale sign
in the in the window I got the number so
I could go home and call that number we
bought the car and I still got her but
Patricia tells us her dad didn't approve
of Ronald so there was a lot of sneaking
around except for sophomore year prom
this was a unique night because this was
one of the few times that her dad her
parents let her go out with me the
couple got engaged a few years later and
as we went through their wedding day
pictures it was as if time Stood Still
our dreams were coming true wasn't going
to be alone okay walking up the aisle
and I looked down and said whoa what a
vision she was gorgeous and they danced
the night away to chances by Johnny
Mathis
chances are fitting for a couple that
took a chance on each other all those
years ago he's my friend my best friend
she's the the girl that I of my dreams
yep always was and always will be
Victoria Saha eight news now
and their anniversary is February 29th a
leap year of course talk about being
especially lucky congrats to them on six
decades been married since 1963.